[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Kyle is
in Nashville hi Kyle welcome to the
Ramsey Show hey Dave it's an honor to
talk to you you too man what's up so I
have two questions today one is a little
bit more straightforward the other one
probably a little bit more complex so uh
the short one is from 29 I have a
seventh Monon old baby and I have
another baby coming in May yay which is
very exciting yes but with that I'm
struggling to figure out given that and
also being an
entrepreneur like should I I feel like I
should have more than six months
emergency fund saved so I'm trying to
figure out what's the right number there
and I'm kind of feeling like no matter
where I get it to I feel like it's not
enough so I'm curious RIS what
event in your mind could occur or would
occur that would require more than 6
months of your expenses to be
covered you know as an entrepreneur I
feel like I'm always thinking worst case
scenarios I'm like if there's a big
recession or who knows if all our
business goes what is the likelihood
you're going to go six months with zero
income probably pretty unlikely yeah
like because as an entrepreneur you
would like get a
job true before that happened right yes
sir or you start you close that business
start another one I don't know but I've
never I've been an entrepreneur my whole
life I've never gone six months without
an income I've never gone a month
without an
income yeah and I've been through some
pretty catastrophic bull crap but I
still didn't go without an
income what do you do what's your
self-employed work what do you do uh I
have a video production firm does your
does your business have savings it does
we have we try to keep three months of
uh runway on hand in cash yeah then I
think you're good I think if you have
your six months how old are you I am 29
29 with a seven-month old and a baby on
the way yes sir you know what you are
you're a good
dad that's what you are no you're a good
dad that's why you're thinking about
this because you're concerned about
taking care of your babies that's what's
making you think about this so but your
math is is fine but the fact that you're
worried about this just all that means
it doesn't mean your system's broken all
that means is you're a good man you just
looked around went I've got
responsibilities and I need to act like
it so you're good you're good okay
awesome and so with that if I have extra
in my current emergency fund should I
reallocate that towards something else
put into Investments put on the mortgage
or dist it's not it's not going to kill
you what kills you is the
concept okay let's say you had seven
months instead of 6 months and you
didn't reallocate it that's not going to
keep you from becoming a millionaire you
understand
but continually adding to that and
looking up there's
$107,000 in there because you
continually haven't dealt intellectually
with this emotional
concern then yeah then then you've
gotten yourself over into stupid land at
that point right yes well I feel like uh
I am in stupid land because that's
exactly how much I have in my right now
107,000 I have in a high yields account
but yeah I'm like hold on oh wow in what
planet is
$100,000 6 months of your
expenses uh it's not we I was I was
shooting for a year and I Justified it
by saying hey well I'm self-employed my
wife's only working part-time now so I
should have more than the normal person
so now what planet is
50,000 6 months of
expenses you have $10,000 a month of
expenses well that kind of leads to my
next question on whether or not my wife
and I need to downsize our house but how
much is your house payment house payment
is 4,200 okay what's your household yeah
okay then 50,000 would be there okay huh
all right yep and so with that what do
you make a
year so uh with bonuses uh take-home is
between like 300 no honey you own the
company what's your taxable
income that's it it's what so my my
personal take-home pay combined with my
wife um like what our take-home after
taxes is 300 to 350 a year way to go
okay all right then I you know maybe
100's not too much if if 100 represents
six months of expenses and you have
48,000 is no that's annualized no you
have 24,000 is your house payment for 6
months yeah so 50 or 60 Grand's probably
enough yeah that the point is you can't
keep doing what you're doing and add you
can't make 100 into 200 into 300 into
400 and savings and and high yield
savings that doesn't make it smart high
yield savings isn't even keeping up with
inflation so I mean you got Biden
inflation at 9% high yield savings
paying four or five so you're running
backwards on every one of those dollars
are you investing at all I am yes I've
started doing 15% yeah yeah and you got
a house payment so I'm going to I'm
going to take 40,000 or 30,000 of that
I'm going to decide 60 or 70 is my
emergency fund anything beyond that I'm
going to throw it at the house and I'm
going to start throwing everything at
the house from now on Beyond 15%
following the baby steps exactly so yeah
your income was a little skewed more
than I thought for some reason I I had a
more normal income in my head but you're
making a lot of money he's doing good
you're doing really good doing so well
yeah you're doing really good